[ __ ] - dammit dreams for when you got
them Hills oh you the hottest [ __ ] in
the please Wow hello hey what is going
on YouTube you know though I've lost a
lot of weight in the past year and a
half or so I still realize that when it
comes to my body weight yeah I'm still
fat fat and delicious but while going
through this weight loss process I
realized that I tend to have fat people
habits and all my chunky brothers and
sisters out there you know you have it
too for example when we go out to eat
you know for a fact that we always have
to finish all of our food and what I
mean by all of our food I'm talking
about every single thing and you're
probably asking this what what if you're
full it doesn't [ __ ] matter what's
full because in our mind that has not
been a technique yet where you can
somehow stop eating and transport that
left over food somewhere else
and they eat it later you know I found
out about something recently though it's
called a to-go box you know my friend
will try to explain to me what that [ __ ]
was and I could not grasp the concept of
it if you're full you stop eating and
then you take it to go listen I don't
know who your African friends to go is
but he is not coming in my house ah what
the [ __ ] are you talking about our you
think I'm stupid
I know he's African my name is Dougal my
god you are fat and you're stupid
tell me why would I know there is
absolutely no food in the fridge I keep
opening it up as if food is magically
going to appear dude why do we do that
that [ __ ] makes no sense we treat our
refrigerator as if it's a magic portal
to a buffet okay ain't nothin in here
hmm no Stanley nothing
dr. Finch goddamn if you're a dude and
you are really chunky for some reason we
randomly squeeze our boobs I don't
[ __ ] know why but I do
and contrary to popular belief no it's
not an erotic thing it's more like I'm
chillin by myself and then I look down
and I'm like hey my god is it Diddy's
and this could partially explain why I'm
an ass man and titties don't really do
it for me
you like these titties you wanna set me
[ __ ] mmm oh [ __ ] you as a fat man I'm
always looking for a way not to sweat
when you are being sweating is
inevitable because your body is trying
to figure out a way to cool your ass
down but it can't do it so it just
starts to cry hey man you okay yeah what
I hate that [ __ ] I am always moist the
only pot boy for me not to be sweaty is
if I doused my whole body in baking
powder or robot when I go to a buffet my
main mission is to make sure that the
restaurant owners regret that I ever
existed and listen I know I don't have
to eat like that but every time I walk
into a buffet I say to myself oh well I
gots to get my money's worth
[ __ ] the amount of food that you
eat you get your money's worth
plus a small village in Uzbekistan trust
me people who own a Chinese buffet look
at me like I'm the Black Plague oh yeah
fat boy goes Wow I'm taking you [ __ ]
out Martha fat fortune cookie [ __ ] I've
all kinds of [ __ ] up and I know for a
fact when I lose all this weight I'm
still doing the same [ __ ] but hey what
is going on YouTube yes yes yes that was
a video I am done with that now
Wednesday we have another life vlog
episode 'you know outputs of working
today and Sunday we have another upload
stay tuned for that
i'ma sketches coming for you guys that
I'm working on and that's just gonna be
[ __ ] hilarious deal with it so you
guys this Wednesday and Sunday and if I
happen to upload an extra video
throughout the week just stay tuned and
subscribe you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh and the notifications but when the
videos come out cuz y'all need to watch
it